welcome back the time is 6 44. las vegas
now hosts mercedes martinez
here to help us rise and shine with a
dose of positive stories joining us live
from the mix 94.1 studios good morning
mercedes
good morning bianca so great to talk to
you this morning we are gonna start with
something
super adorable today check this out
i found this video on tick tock it is
ducklings
waddling around with a little puppy and
he has a little bird on his back
what is cuter than baby animals bianca
i'm telling you that's going to start
your day off right
that is cute you know it looks like
something out of a cartoon just a
collection of all the animals
you know and just all together like
you're at a petting zoo or something
that is i love it and and just
how they're all friends with each other
nobody knows that they're different from
one another it's perfect
and you know they have there have been
those stories where you know a
cat or a dog will kind of raise the
other and opposite situations so i think
you know when animals are that young
they don't know the difference right i
know
i think us humans could get a very good
lesson from that i don't know what do
you think
i believe so well you know mercedes
recently i flew
and i'm girlfriend i didn't have this
experience it's bad enough when someone
takes their shoes off but
to put them next to you no thanks
what happened mercedes they're very
gross
check this out thanks to tick tock we
now know what to do and how you can fix
that situation so this was posted online
recently
the guy shows the foot just chilling on
his armrest
and then a bottle of water whoops just a
little waddle
dribbled on the stranger's foot and it
is quickly removed
from the armrest back to
flying foot free or maybe you make a
sneezing noise and just splash a little
bit i guarantee they will stay out of
your personal space
but i wonder did he ask him first like
did he say hey man
you know what can you move your feet and
then he didn't do it and then he kind of
was like okay let me take
the next measure and pour some water do
you think he did that
part of me says that that's a no-brainer
he shouldn't have done that in the first
place i'm not asking i'm splashing
come on we gotta you know what instead
of the safety measures because i feel
like we all know the safety measures as
far as putting on your mask
we need uh some you know one-on-one tips
and how to be a good fellow passenger
like the middle the person in the middle
seat gets both arm rests right
don't put your feet up on this next
person's chair
and if you are having snacks bring some
for everyone around you because i get so
jealous of the people eating snacks and
i've got nothing
agreed because you know there's hardly
any food places open at the airport
anymore so
that is smart idea just make sure it
doesn't stink up the airplane
yes nothing with onions no sandwiches
with onions please
all right well thanks mercedes